face à ces machins avec les deux sens
alex gagnon et des cinq autres membres
de sa famille dont eu que quelques
heures pour quitter leur maison ils ont
amené que le strict nécessaire
cet écrasant ya aucune garantie que la
maison va pouvoir réintégrer le domicile
on n'est même pas capable de retourner
chercher de matériel accompagnés ou non
une trentaine de familles comme la
sienne n'ont actuellement aucun endroit
où rester la croix rouge leur paye
l'hébergement
la soeur d'alex mégane a dû se départir
temporairement de ces animaux ils sont
hébergés dans une animalerie et ça me
fait de la peine au mexique tout le
monde est en santé tout le monde voit
bien fatigué bien ça se remplace les
animaux mes parents mes frères et soeurs
tout le monde voit bien un glissement de
terrain est inévitable selon la ville et
les résidents autour du secteur condamné
craignent que le périmètre ne soit
élargi je me dis que c'est hors de mon
contrôle fac c'est pour
ça sert à rien dans un souci est trop la
ville de saguenay et québec le
reconnaissent les compensations
actuelles ne sont pas suffisantes
quelque 200 mille dollars en
compensation 1,20 dollar pour se loger
par jour vous comprendrez que dans le
contexte actuel ça ne tient pas la route
des programmes qui existent déjà si
c'est nécessaire de les bonifier on sait
que quelqu'un qui perd sa maison dans
une situation comme ça elle droit 260
mille dollars on travaille aussi avec la
mairesse julie faux avec la croix rouge
pour être certain qu'on aide tout le
monde à se trouver un logement puis aidé
financièrement toutes les familles en
après-midi la sécurité publique a tenu
une rencontre d'information avec les
sinistrés je rends compte que c'est
vraiment juste pour l'aide financière de
2,2 puis rien de nouveau que moi en fait
je connaissais pas ce que ça nous a été
annoncée de façon officielle mais c'est
les mêmes montants que les autres mais
la question sur toutes les lèvres
pourront-ils ou non réintégrer un jour
leur maison c'est tout les années qu'on
le pensait dans sa maison alors c'est le
sentiment d'appartenance
sellal et souvenez pour l'instant c'est
l'incertitude
ici marc isabelle rochon radio canada
saguenay